[MUSIC PLAYING]
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE: Here's
a quick look at the agenda.
We'll do a bit of level
setting around big data--
challenges and opportunities.
But then, very
quickly, we're going
to move to the second part
of the session, where we're
going to go through a
hypothetical retail scenario
to do a lot of demos and
hands-on usage of the product,
and really show you in practice
how they work, what they do.
And then, as mentioned,
Hooyeon will come and talk
about Moloco's experience in
real life using those services
to build their application.
So speaking of the big data
challenges, to a large extent,
I assume most of you
know those firsthand,
just having experienced them.
I'm not going to
list all of them.
But among some of
the obvious ones
around the technical
difficulties
of setting up and managing
and optimizing infrastructure,
ingesting data, the
one in that list
which is the most near and dear
to my heart is really around 5,
6, 7.
It's about not just kind
of the basics-- of course
you need data system
and capabilities.
But what we really need to do is
change the way people interact
and get value from
that data and move
to a much more iterative and
explorative mode, where people
have the freedom to experiment.
You know, it doesn't take a
long time to try something.
It doesn't cost a lot of
money to try something.
And so we really
change the dynamic
of how people work with data.
And that's really--
you know, when
I see customers get
to that point, that's
when I know that they're being
successful on the platform.
You know, them getting to having
X amount data on the platform,
that says nothing.
Them getting to the point
where they're really
changing the way
they get insight,
that is the key moment.
And one part of that is
the collaboration, also.
Seeing collaboration enabled by
the services that we describe,
within one organization or
even across organizations,
is also one of
those aha moments,
where we move from traditional
big data, just easier,
to a different way to
get value from the data.
So hopefully, you'll
see that in practice.
In terms of what
it's used for, it
depends a lot on the
various industries.
Obviously, some
aspects are pretty
common across industries.
You know, most companies
have a marketing department.
Most companies--
hopefully all of them--
have financial data,
and actually make money,
and want to keep track of it.
And some of the use cases
are much more specific
to inventory
management in retail,
or maintenance in manufacturing,
and things like that.
So you know better than me
what your industry is about.
But these are typical examples
that we see quite often.
In this session, when
we say "big data,"
we really include AI
and ML in that context.
Now, here at Next, there
are many sessions around AI.
So we're not going to go
into the details of it.
But the way we think about
it-- the way we've built
the platform--
is that AI is really the
prolongation of a data
platform.
It's not something that you
do instead of a data platform.
You still have to have
control of your data.
You still have to bring the
data and understand your data.
But it really is an
extended set of capabilities
that are part of the platform.
And that's how we've built it.
And we'll describe this
integration as well
as we go through the session.
So a very quick level
overview of the portfolio.
We'll describe many of
those services in practice
through the demos.
But an easy way to think
about it is to break down
the lifecycle of the data
into four main stages,
starting on the left
side, by ingestion,
and whether you're talking
real-time ingestion--
and we'll talk about
Pub/Sub as an event broker,
that's often used for that--
or batch mode ingestion.
And we'll talk about transfer
service or many other ways
to integrate data and
bring it to the platform.
After that phase of
ingestion, typically, data
needs to be prepared.
Sometimes, data comes
in almost ready,
and so you really just have
to move it to the right place.
But by and large,
most of the time
it needs some level of
preparation, some level
of cleaning and enrichment.
And so we'll talk about services
like DataFlow and DataProc
that support that and
actually do the work,
as well as tools
like DataPrep, which
is a very easy-to-use,
GUI-driven tool that
allows non-technical
specialists to do their own data
preparation.
And so that allows--
not just at the
preparation, but then
that stage of the lifecycle,
also, more and more,
is where some of the
analytics happen.
Some of the analytics
happens in real time.
We'll show that here in the
case of the retail example.
But of course, data is
then stored and analyzed.
And we'll talk about BigQuery
for analytics and data
warehousing.
And then, downstream, I
mentioned ML and data science.
We'll show the
visualization tools,
the places where the data is
actually used and consumed
by users.
So a very high-level overview.
The point here is that
this session, we'll
talk about the full life cycle,
and GCP data platform is built
to address the full lifecycle.
So we'll talk about
individual services
and their capabilities,
but in the end,
maybe the most important
thing is actually not
what each service does.
Its what they have in common.
It's the key principles that
are at the foundation of Google
Cloud and that shine through
all of the services, so one
of them being integrated.
You know, the last thing
we want is data silos.
And a lot of customers--
especially those who move from
on-prem systems--
they're moving from
a very siloed view
of the world, where some data
is in the data warehouse.
Some data is in
the Hadoop cluster.
Some data is somewhere else.
And where the data is limits
what you can do with it.
And so this we a long time
ago rejected internally.
And when the time came for
us to build Google Cloud,
we've brought that philosophy of
separating processing from data
and having data in
all storage system
accessible from
all pricing system.
And we'll see that in practice.
And it has a drastic effect.
You know, it's simpler.
It's more effective.
But going back to the
collaboration and exploration
use cases I describe, it
really opens up the door
to a lot more and much faster
usage and collaboration.
Serverless is the other big one.
It's the fact that
moving to Cloud
does not just mean not
dealing with hardware anymore.
That's a very basic
version of Cloud.
Moving to Cloud
really should mean
not having to worry about the
how, about the infrastructure,
allowing you to focus on
bringing your business
expertise, your
understanding of the data,
describing what you want
to get done, and that's it,
and having the platform
just make it happen,
and without you having to
set up machine, or configure
clusters, and decide how
many workers you need,
things like that.
Serverless takes that
burden away from you,
and we take care of it.
And then finally, openness.
Everything we do is either
a cloud-native service
that we built from the start
as a multi-tenant serverless
system or a service where we
took the best of open source
and brought it to Google.
In the first case, even though
it's something that originated
at Google, we always open source
the tool itself-- the SDK,
the relevant pieces--
such that, as you use those
cloud-native services on Google
Cloud, what you're
using is open source
tools, standard interfaces, such
that there's never any locking,
and there is a
rich community that
builds on top of those tools.
And we'll see that in practice
when we talk about some
of those tools.
So let's now move to the
second part of the session.
And Win is going to set
up the stage for you
on the hypothetical example
that we'll use for that.
WIN WOO: OK.
Thank you very much, William.
So in my hometown of
Sydney, in Australia,
I go to Bill's Grocer--
or not exactly Bill's
Grocer, but a chain very much
similarly named.
So in this example,
I thought about what
a scaled version
of Bill's Grocer
might look like if
he had multiple sales
channels, and nationwide
networks of physical stores,
as well as an online
presence where
he can sell groceries online.
So in this new version
of Bill's Grocer,
where they're a multinational
chain, potentially,
and with multiple
sales channels,
I thought about the
sort of data analytics
that Bill's Grocer
might want to perform.
So the first might be to
understand the different types
of omni-channel interactions
associated with the selling
channels.
For example, on Bill's
Grocer's website,
Bill's Grocer will want to
understand, how are people
actually interacting
with the website?
Were they actually leaving
before they make a purchase?
How can Bill's Grocer optimize
the actual website experience?
On the physical
sales channel front,
if we look at point-of-sale
sale analytics,
there's a lot of insight
that Bill's Grocer
could stand to
advantage themselves
in terms of how they
optimize their business.
For example, if we're
to go beyond what
are the typical sales volumes
and types of products that
are being bought, more
advanced analytics
can contain things like, what
are commonly-bought products
that are bought with other
products in the store,
and how can that
affect placement
of individual products in store?
Now, even though my imaginary
version of Bill's Grocer
is now a very large
chain, because they
want to retain the
small-town local grocer feel,
Bill's Grocer wants
to still continue
to maintain that close
customer relationship
and thereby understand
customer feedback
through various
different means, but also
be able to scale that as well.
So in my imaginary
scenario, we're
going to incorporate some
methods to understand
customer sentiment
and feedback at scale
as our batch
processing scenario.
So in terms of our
solution goals,
I think William alluded
to a lot of the things
and characteristics that
you should try and find
within a data platform.
And we'll try and encompass
this within our solution today.
So even though Bill's
Grocer, from a small business
through to my large
imaginary business--
whatever the size,
Bill's Grocer should not
be focused on infrastructure
or the machinery,
the mechanics required to
run data systems at scale.
Rather, like you,
Bill's Grocer wants
to focus on the insights that
can be derived from data.
And that involves
more than just being
able to process and
store data at scale,
but to be able to convert the
data into an insight quickly.
One of the ways that
we'll do this today
is to incorporate
streaming analytics
into our different scenarios and
show how you can convert data
into different insights that
can benefit the business as
quickly as possible.
Doing lots of advance
queries to generate insight
is only one part
of the equation.
Another part of the equation
is how people will actually
work with insights and how
to communicate information
to different stakeholders.
So as part of our
demonstration scenario,
we're showing different types
of tools that are targeted
at different types of users--
whether it's technical users,
or business stakeholders-- that
is actually commensurate
with the type of usage
that they will get from the
system, or the type of insights
they want to derive.
So I'll be showing different
visualization tools, as well as
collaboration tools
that integrate directly
into the platform.
As we scale analytics,
it's important
that we don't ignore
data privacy concerns.
So as part of our
scenario, we'll
be showing different
technologies that
allow you to factor
in private information
and avoid having that exposed
in our analytics pipeline.
So we'll be showing some
APIs that will accomplish
that capability at scale.
And then, lastly,
with the combination
of all these different
elements, we'll
hopefully have a system
ready for Bill's Grocer that
will not just mean a
happy set of customers,
but ultimately, those
happy customers leading
to a happy business for Bill.
So with that, I want
to pass back to William
to elaborate further.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE: Thank you.
Can I take the box?
Thank you.
So when we talk
about the toolset,
maybe one way to set the
stage to help understand
how we came to the
stage where we are right
now is to think about the
history of data processing
at Google, which,
as you can imagine,
started long before
Google had a cloud.
You know, for the first
part of its existence,
Google was only building
technology for its own use,
starting research,
and other services.
And so, when you start as
a company with the goal
to index the entire
web, obviously you
have a scale problem
from day one.
But also, solving scale is
actually not the hardest part.
The hardest part is
solving scale efficiently,
doing it in a way that is very
cost efficient from a resource
perspective, also from a human
productivity perspective.
And that's how Google can
offer services for free.
Its really dealing with
scale and productivity.
And so there's a long list of
papers that were published.
Those are internal technology
that are now known to the world
because Google published papers.
And at the time, Google
just published the papers
and then moved on, to develop
the next internal system.
People outside Google,
reading those papers
and learning how
Google was using that,
wanted to have access to them.
And at the time, the
only way to have access
was to reimplement it.
And so systems like Hadoop,
and Edgebase, and others
were created, basically, by
reimplementing those papers
that had been published.
From a Google perspective,
that was fine.
That's why we
published the paper.
But we were not involved in
those non-Google use cases.
That changed with the advent
of Cloud in several ways.
So what has not changed is
we still publish papers.
So recently, DataFlow and
TensorFlow-- and there
are more coming up that
are in review stage.
But now, when we
publish a paper,
we also open source
the code behind it.
And so TensorFlow
is now open source.
Apache Beam, which we'll
talk about a bit more later,
is the result of Google open
sourcing the DataFlow SDK,
giving it to the
Apache Foundation.
And so, instead of
having to re-implement,
people can now use
that using the code
that Google uses internally.
And the services themselves are
made available on Google Cloud.
And so we'll start with
BigQuery as a first example,
and then we'll talk
about some others.
So BigQuery is kind
of the successor
of the original Dremel engine,
which of course has seen
a lot of improvements
and re-engineering
over the last 10 years.
But it is one of the
workhorses of data processing
at Google, available
as a cloud service.
So let's talk a bit
more about BigQuery.
In a way, the
one-line description
is a cloud data warehouse.
And that's just-- that's
both good and bad.
In a way, it's true, because
anything a data warehouse
can do, BigQuery can do.
You use standard SQL
to interact with it.
You can use all your favorite
data visualization tools.
You know, it has ODBC, JDBC
drivers, an API, a CLI,
a rich ecosystem of partners.
You know, it is a true,
first-class enterprise data
warehouse.
It's also more than
that in the way
that it's a cloud-native
data warehouse.
And Reza, in his demo, will
call out some of the aspects.
It's serverless.
It's separate storage
from processing.
And, as we announced
this morning,
it also has a lot
of new capabilities
that make it much
more versatile.
And so this morning, we
announced BigQuery ML
to do machine learning
directly in BigQuery using SQL.
We also announced an
upcoming feature--
to have GIS queries.
So you'll have geo-queries
based on location information
in your data that allows you
to query in a geo-specific way.
And so that's another example
of the versatility of BigQuery
that is pretty
cool to the system.
One aspect is, how do you
get data into BigQuery?
You know, because, to be
useful, it has to have data.
Now, that being
said, there's already
a lot of public datasets
that are available directly
in BigQuery.
And so you can go and try
and use it at large scale
without bringing your own data.
But most customers, obviously,
want to bring their own data.
Many ways to do that.
A lot of marketing data can
be brought automatically,
especially if it's
already at Google.
You know, if it's ad
data, or analytics data,
or if you're a YouTube
publisher, all of that
data, you can just
say, I want that data
brought into BigQuery.
You have nothing to do
there other than just
saying, "I want it."
We have a rich ecosystem
of partners in the ETL data
integration space to bring
data from enterprise software
on-prem, from other
clouds, and SaaS vendors.
And then, on the
right side, if you
build systems that
write to BigQuery,
BigQuery is very well-equipped
to do streaming ingestion.
And so events, flying through
Pub/Sub or other streaming
system, you can have
them flow into BigQuery
and be immediately
available in your queries.
You know, you just pump
events and query on them,
so very easy, very optimized for
streaming ingestion, as well,
of course, as supporting
batch ingestion through GCS--
Google Cloud Storage--
including taking advantage
of the many ways we
can bring data to GCS,
including cloud storage transfer
service to bring data online
or offline.
You know, you can
bring petabytes
using physical
devices, and many ways
to bring data to GCS that
can flow then into BigQuery.
And so let's see
that in practice,
and Reza will show us.
REZA ROKNI: Thank you.
So let me just switch this over.
Great.
OK.
So what we're going to
do is run some queries
against a couple of datasets.
Now, Win mentioned
click stream data--
so this is the data
coming from the website.
So we're going to run
a query against data
that we've obtained by Google
Analytics 360 Premium, that
has been loaded into BigQuery.
We're also going
to run some queries
against a transactional
point-of-sale dataset.
Now, this is actually
a petabyte of data
that we're going to run
some queries against,
just to show the
ability of BigQuery
to run queries against
very large datasets.
Now, before we start, I'd like
to point out one of the pieces
that William brought up around
BigQuery's architecture.
So BigQuery separates
processing from storage--
which is part of the reason it
is able to do what it can do.
But what does that mean to you?
So the first thing
it provides is
that, if you're not running
any queries on BigQuery,
you don't need to pay for
any servers that are sitting
around waiting for work.
So that's one aspect.
The other aspect is around
the sharing of data,
both within the organization
and from external sources
to the organization.
So how does that work?
If we think about a
traditional database,
you have your software that
you install into some machines,
then you attach SAN,
NAS, disk, et cetera.
This thing becomes a unit.
You then push
information into it.
And now, to get access
to that information,
you either need to give access
directly to the database--
I used to be a DBA.
This is not something I would
let people do very easily--
or you have an
application layer that you
need to build on top
and deal with things
like multi-tenancy, et cetera,
or you do the FTP dance.
And nobody likes to
do the FTP dance.
It's tedious and boring and
leads to lots of problems.
So what we're going
to do is actually
show the separation of
processing and storage
and what it means.
Here we have the new
BigQuery user interface.
It was recently pushed
out with this new version,
for those of you who've
used BigQuery before.
On the top here, we can see
that I am in the DA101 project.
So this is the
project I am going
to be running my queries from.
On the left-hand side, as
well as the DA101 project,
we can actually
see other projects
that I have been
granted access to.
So through the proper
security and authorization ACL
mechanisms, I've been given
access to these datasets.
Now, this particular dataset,
the retail petabyte dataset,
which I'm going to highlight
here, has some tables in it.
And again, this is a table that
exists in a different project.
I've just been
given access to it,
so I'll run my query
from here against that.
This sales partition table--
just to look at the structure--
it's got a sales order key.
This is that
point-of-sale information.
And if we look at
the types of data
that we're allowed
to store, as well
as the standard ones you have
here, we have a record type.
So this record, there's
a single sales order key,
and there are many
lines of information,
because BigQuery
supports repeated fields
within a column.
So let's go and actually
look at some more details
around this table.
So here, we're going to
start discovering that,
despite the name, Bill's Grocer
is actually hugely successful,
because they have over one
petabyte of data in their sales
information-- which we
can highlight here--
and over one trillion
rows of information.
So that's a lot of sales that
these guys have been making.
I'm assuming it's a
very big Bill's Grocer.
Now, what we're
going to do is, we're
going to run a deliberately
inefficient query.
So this particular query
that I'm going to run,
I'm going to try and find
the sales information to date
for a particular customer,
denoted by this customer key.
I'm going to kick that
off now, and that's
going to take a little
while to complete.
Just a note-- actually,
that was cheating.
Let me turn off caching.
So BigQuery will cache results
of a query that's been recently
run, for up to 24 hours.
Let me run that again.
So that's now going to take
a little while to complete.
What I'd like to point out
on the right-hand side is,
even though there's a petabyte
of information in that table,
we're only going to
process 31 terabytes.
It's still a pretty big number.
And we're still going to
process all of the rows.
The reason for that is BigQuery
has a column I/O storage
structure.
So what that means is, if
you're going to only access
a few of the columns
from the table
within your select
statement, it only
needs to process
those columns, and it
ignores the rest of the data.
So here, it doesn't need
to access any other columns
other than the three
we have in this query.
Now, because that's going to
take a little while to run,
I'm going to quickly
move over to another tab
and show some of the other
features of BigQuery.
So first of all, what
I'd like to point out
is this is the area that
we can actually start
building our queries against.
So we can start typing in
and we can do autocomplete.
However, when we're doing
ad hoc queries, et cetera,
it's obviously nice
to have a scratch pad
area, so somewhere where you'll
save your queries for use
by yourself later on.
So for that, if we
look at Saved Queries,
we have two environments.
We have the Personal
Queries, which
is my personal area
where I can leave queries
that I want to come back to.
Or, if you want to
share your queries--
so you've built that beautiful
query, 30 lines long,
and you want to share it with
your colleagues and show off--
we can actually do that
through Project Queries.
So here, we can save
our queries and then
share it with my colleagues,
like William and Win, who
can then go and access this
query, work on it, or run it.
And we're going to choose a
particular query, which is
this Google Analytics 360 data.
This particular query is going
to look at the click stream
data that's been imported
from Google Analytics 360,
and it's going to tell me which
sources have generated the most
bounce rates from our dataset.
Now, by "bounce rate," we mean
a user has just come and not
viewed any more pages on
the first page they came to.
So first of all, I'm going
to load this query in.
And see, it's been
loaded into the top here.
I'm going to run this
query now, and that
will take about five,
six seconds to complete.
It's finished.
And we can see here that
it's gone through the Google
Analytics 360 data,
and provided insights
to us about the sources that
have been sending clicks to us,
and the number of visits--
the number of times that we've
only landed on a single page.
Just to show some of the
other features of BigQuery--
so on this side,
I'm going to create
a dataset, which is
the container that we
can load tables into.
Here we have the Dataset ID.
But on data locations, we
can choose several regions--
United States, European
Union, or Tokyo.
So these are the regions
that the data will reside
in when we create this dataset.
In terms of the
other functions here,
we have a default
table expiration.
So this is super useful.
When you're actually
building out some queries,
sometimes you want to build
some temporary tables.
There's a couple of reasons
you'll want to do that.
For example, you're running
a particularly large query
and you want to explore
the dataset that is
the result of that large query.
So for that, you'll just run the
large query, create this table,
and you don't want
to then have to think
about deleting it afterwards.
So by creating a dataset
with this expiration level,
we can say number of days.
Let's say we create a
dataset called "temporary."
We can create these
temporary tables
and know that, after
about five, six days,
they're automatically going
to get cleaned up for us.
The other reason you also
need temporary tables
is when you are building a
particularly large query,
and it's very useful
sometimes to just
take out the inner
part of that query
while you explore
the outer parts.
I'm going to now--
also, I said that
the query that we
were running against that very
large dataset was inefficient.
Just to show a more efficient
version of that query using
some features that recently
released around clusters
and a slightly older feature
around partition tables--
so if I go to Saved Queries,
and look at our Project Queries,
and customer cluster optimized--
so I'm going to open this one.
So this particular query
is making use of some dates
to limit the pool, and
it's using a specific range
of customer keys.
If we look at this sales
partitioned cluster table,
it is of a similar size to
the table we saw before--
around a petabyte.
But when I run this
query, it's actually
going to complete in about--
again, I need to turn this off.
There we go.
So this will complete in
about 10 to 20 seconds.
And if we look on
the right-hand side,
it's actually having to
process a lot less data.
And the reason for
that is it's actually
using some smarts around--
because the partition
table is by date,
it's been able to
prune information
it doesn't need to access.
And it's clustered
by our customer key.
So that is going to
complete, hopefully,
in a few more seconds.
There we go.
That was the result of
that one finishing--
18 seconds.
And now we're going to go
back to the original query.
And here, we see that that
larger query processed
31 terabytes, went
through a trillion rows
in two minutes and just a
few seconds on top of that.
Now, the last thing I
want to show you here
is this table stock.
If I go to this stock
table and look at details--
we expand this further up here.
And I'm not able to
use the scroll bar.
There we go-- we notice that
it's actually got streaming
buffer stats underneath.
One of the things
that William mentioned
is that BigQuery supports
streaming inserts directly
into BigQuery, which means we
can continuously update tables,
and when we make a query call,
it's using the latest data.
So here, the
point-of-sale system
is continually updating
sales to BigQuery.
And when we run a
query, it's going
to be with the most
up-to-date data.
Now, if we can go
back to the slides--
OK.
And now the ticker.
So how do we get that streaming?
So one of the ways
is through the API
that BigQuery directly exposes.
And you can build applications
that use that API directly.
However, most of the
customers I work with
will actually use
other mechanisms
to be able to do this,
predominantly using things
like Pub/Sub and Dataflow.
So if we think about
a streaming pipeline,
when we've got
messages coming in,
we need some way of actually
absorbing those messages.
And Google Cloud Pub/Sub
is our global publish
and subscribe API.
It's able to absorb
messages onto a topic.
And it also acts as a
very good shock absorber.
So if you imagine you have a
very high spike in requests
that you weren't expecting,
or you have some problems
downstream, Pub/Sub
will retain information
for up to seven days.
And I've seen it used very
effectively in that mode
with quite a few customers.
So now that we've got a
way of actually absorbing
these messages, we need a way of
transporting them from Pub/Sub
over to the BigQuery table.
And for that, we're
going to use DataFlow,
which allows you to
do batch and stream
processing in a distributed
way, being able to scale out
at very large scale.
If we think of the
end-to-end pipeline here,
we have the
point-of-sale system.
There is an application
that is writing
the messages into Pub/Sub
as sales are happening.
DataFlow is doing a
very simple task here,
which is to transport
those messages from Pub/Sub
over to BigQuery using
that streaming API, which
allows us to get
queries immediately
up-to-date on what's
happening within the business.
So when I first
started doing this--
I've been at Google five years--
we tended to have to write
code to spin up any Dataflow
pipeline.
And that was even
for the simple stuff.
Here, since then,
we've actually got
these fantastic templates,
which allow you to go to the UI,
complete the template,
and it will automatically
transport the
information from Pub/Sub
to BigQuery, spinning up
Dataflow in the background.
And to actually see
that in action, Win
is going to show us a demo.
WIN WOO: Yes, indeed.
Thank you very much, Reza.
OK.
So let's go back to the
Cloud platform console.
And there's a few
things that we need
to get the first
streaming pipeline that we
want to run working.
The first part is Pub/Sub.
So let's go into the
Pub/Sub configuration.
The first thing that we
need to do in Pub/Sub
is to create a Pub/Sub
topic that we'll
be using to read
or ingest messages
from a streaming source.
In this particular
case, we'll be
using a hypothetical
point-of-sale system
that will be sending messages
to the Pub/Sub topic.
Let's go ahead and
create the topic.
To do that, I click on
the Create Topic button,
I give it a unique ID, like
a POS_DATA, click Create,
and there I have my new topic.
It is now ready to accept
streaming messages.
The second part that
I need to perform
is to provision the
DataFlow pipeline.
To do that, I can use one of
the pre-prepared templates that
lets me create the
DataFlow pipeline,
take the messages from
the Pub/Sub topic,
and then write them
into a BigQuery table.
In order to do that, here is an
existing template configuration
that I've already
pre-typed out so
that you don't have to watch me
continually make syntax errors.
All these details
are all you need
to have a simple pipeline
that takes the Pub/Sub
messages right to a BigQuery
table, all without code.
I'm going to click on Run Job
here to provision the job.
And the next screen
that I'll be taken to
will show the pipeline
being provisioned,
as well as a way to
visualize the actual DataFlow
graph itself.
Now, because it's going to
take a little bit of time--
as in, maybe, 60, 90 seconds,
something like that--
to really get the
pipeline up and running,
I'm going to go into a
pre-prepared pipeline which
already has data
streaming into it to show
you some of the more important
parts of the DataFlow
interface.
The first is, obviously,
the pipeline itself.
What you see here, with the
different rectangles organized,
as I said, as connected
nodes in a graph,
is actually the different
transformations and operations
on the data that the pipeline
is performing in order
to read the messages, do
some simple transformation,
and then write to
an output table.
So the Pub/Sub
messages transformation
is represented by
this box, which
is for reading the
Pub/Sub messages.
On the right-hand
side, you'll see
some interesting information
about the actual step itself.
The step is parallelized across
different DataFlow workers,
which means that, because
we're running a distributed
service that can scale to,
really, any sort of data scale
that you want to throw
into the pipeline,
you can see what the
performance of the pipeline
is like in the context of
the number of different data
elements that have
been added in history
as well as the size
of all the elements
that have been processed
by that particular step.
Now, if I actually don't
click on any step at all,
you'll see some overall
statistics about the pipeline.
So if you look
into auto-scaling,
we can see that
currently there's
one worker operating
all the different steps
of the pipeline itself.
There's not a lot
of data flowing
inside the pipeline
at the moment,
so right now, one
worker is sufficient.
As more data goes
into the pipeline,
the DataFlow service, as
a serverless offering,
will automatically scale
up the number of workers
to meet the volume
and throughput that
is needed by your application.
So all that stuff is
without you needing
to configure any
infrastructure or to configure
any concerns about scaling.
You can see within the
pipeline that there
is other information shown,
like the number of elements
processed within each step.
So for example, we have
24 elements a second
being written out to our
target table within BigQuery.
So again, it's low volume.
But that shows you some
more interesting information
about what your pipeline
is actually doing.
Now that we've explained
the DataFlow pipeline,
let's actually look at the
output of the streaming
DataFlow pipeline itself, in the
context of the BigQuery table
it's being written to.
So I'm going to go into the
BigQuery interface again.
And to, again,
save me on typing,
I'm going to bring up a saved
query which I've pre-prepared
ahead of time, and bring
up this particular query,
which I will run very shortly.
But I've actually omitted
a particular part,
which is to actually get
some real-time data on stage
right now.
So I'd like to, actually, bring
up Reza into the demonstration
as well.
Actually, why don't
you stand here, Reza,
because I think it's better
if you operate from there.
I'm going to need to
do something inelegant
alt-tabbing here.
So I did say that this was a
point-of-sale demonstration,
so I did say it
was hypothetical,
but we did go to the
effort of actually building
a hypothetical, green screen
point-of-sale application,
which, as you can see,
is very, very attractive.
And Reza here is
going to help me
purchase some products at one
of Bill's Grocer's stores.
I'm an Australian, and I
always get very homesick
whenever I travel.
So I want to buy
some goodies here
to basically get through
the long days of the travel.
REZA ROKNI: There we go.
So that's one.
WIN WOO: All right.
REZA ROKNI: Hit Enter there.
And these are delicious.
And hit Enter there.
WIN WOO: This one's
actually my favorite.
REZA ROKNI: There we go.
WIN WOO: All right.
OK.
So you can definitely see that
I'm a bit of a chocolate fan.
Are you going to start
eating my demonstration?
REZA ROKNI: It's four o'clock.
I'm hungry.
WIN WOO: You know what?
I'm very jealous right now.
I can't eat it.
Maybe I'll eat after this
particular demo is done.
So what's actually
happening here
is I've purchased four products.
Each time a product
has been purchased,
there's a streaming Pub/Sub
message written to the Pub/Sub
topic, which is then read
using our DataFlow pipeline,
processed, and then
written to our output
BigQuery table, all
in near real-time.
So we see here that the
current invoice number is this.
So let's go and check
the outputs of our table.
So, actually, I think
I need to copy this
so I don't get it wrong.
And I'm going to query the
table that should have received
the output, run the
query, and with some luck,
I should see the products
that I've just bought.
So there you go-- a
streaming pipeline
taking data from real
time streaming source, all
without code.
Back to you, William.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE: All right.
Thank you.
I'll switch back to the slides.
So what we saw here
is that pipeline
where you can use
DataFlow without having
to write any code--
sorry.
I'm clicking on
the wrong screen.
There we go-- without
having to write any code,
because the DataFlow
pipeline that was executing
has been pre-created for
a given task to bring data
from Pub/Sub to BigQuery.
Now, DataFlow can do
that, but DataFlow
can do a lot more than that.
It's really a full-fledged
processing system.
And so let's talk more about the
broader range of capabilities
of DataFlow.
And again, going back
to this historical view,
where DataFlow comes from
is really two things.
FlumeJava is a system that
we developed at Google
as a replacement for MapReduce,
a more efficient, easier way
to create and run large scale
data processing pipelines
in batch mode.
In parallel,
another team created
MillWheel which is a system
for stream processing.
Because at that time, there
was a clear move within Google
to real-time data processing,
and MillWheel met that need.
In DataFlow, what
we've done is we've
brought those two separate
services together and unified
them in DataFlow.
So it's unified from a
programming perspective,
where the same pipeline can
run in batch or in stream mode.
It's also unified from the
execution environment, where
one service can
submit a pipeline
and it runs both of them.
And so that's really
the genesis of DataFlow.
Having done that, and delivering
on that openness philosophy
that I describe, we open
sourced the DataFlow SDK.
We gave it to the
Apache Foundation,
where it's now
called Apache Beam.
And Beam-- the "B" of
"Beam" stands for batch,
and the "EAM" stands for stream.
And so, really, what
that name represents
is a unification
of batch and stream
in one programming model.
And that's one thing that's
really, really important
to Beam, because it maps
to a real need, where
more and more, we
see companies move
from a very batch-centric
view to a more real-time view.
But that doesn't
happen overnight.
It's a progressive
process, where
some of your sources, some
of your pipelines move.
And when that happens,
you don't want
to have to re-implement
your business logic.
You just want to be able to take
your pipeline and say, hey--
you know, what used to be a file
drop every four hours is now
a streaming pipeline.
Run the same business
logic on this data
and don't make me rewrite it.
And so Beam does that very well.
It also works the
other way around.
I have a streaming pipeline,
but once in a while
I want to reprocess
historical information.
No problem.
Take the pipeline,
run it in batch
mode against
historical information.
And so that is something that is
a characteristic of Beam itself
in Apache.
And the Apache work is actually
not tied to Google in any way.
And so those Beam
pipelines that you write
can run anywhere you want.
They can run on
the Spark cluster.
They can run on other
Apache processing systems,
like Flink, if you're
familiar with Flink,
or just recently, our
friends at LinkedIn
open-sourced the Samza Runner.
There is one for Apex.
There is one for Gearpump.
And so there are many
different systems where
you can run those pipelines.
Google Cloud DataFlow
is just another one.
And so the pipelines
are portable.
If you run them on
DataFlow, what you get
is the benefit of a
serverless environment.
And so you don't have
to deploy a cluster
and then run your pipelines.
You just submit a pipeline.
Just tell Google, "run
this for me in batch mode,"
or, "run this for
me in stream mode."
And Google automatically
provisions the right amount
of workers, continuously
auto-scales them
through the life
of the pipeline,
and executes the pipeline.
And you don't have to worry
about any infrastructure.
You just have to
write your pipeline,
describe what you
want to get done.
And that's really
the core of DataFlow
from an operational perspective.
One thing I would
add is DataFlow
is a very generic, very
versatile data processing
mechanism for any kind of
large scale data processing.
Data preparation
for machine learning
is one of the sweet spots.
In a way, in machine
learning, before you train,
you have to prepare your data.
That typically
happens in batch mode.
And then you train and
you create your model.
When the time comes to use
your model for scoring,
you have to take the
input data and prepare it
in the exact same way that
you prepared it for training.
You know, not doing
that is one of the most
common sources of problems
with machine learning.
And so Beam allows you
to use that same pipeline
at scoring time now.
And scoring can happen
as a batch or stream.
And so, again, you
get that flexibility.
And that's the reason why,
internally, we really use
the two together very commonly.
And we've built tools
on top of Apache Beam
to make it easier to prepare
data for machine learning
and prepare it for TensorFlow.
And those tools are being
open sourced as well.
And so, again, Beam and
DataFlow are generic data
processing services, but really
with a very strong sweet spot
for being used more and
more often in machine
learning context.
And so, in a way, this is what
it looks like all put together.
In this case, the streaming
use case where data flows from
whatever endpoint-- mobile
application, IOT devices--
into an event bus, like Pub/Sub,
that we showed just earlier--
you know, serverless event
bus, or Kafka, or others--
into DataFlow for stream
processing, and then
straight into BigQuery
or other systems--
you know, Bigtable or GCS--
and then use with ML.
So that's really where it fits
in that end-to-end pipeline.
And Win is going to
show in more detail what
DataFlow does in practice.
WIN WOO: Absolutely.
So in the first pipeline,
we utilized a very simple
example--
reading messages
directly from Pub/Sub
and then writing them
directly to a BigQuery table.
In this particular example,
we're going to break the glass
and implement some more
sophisticated analytics that
will be useful for
deriving insight later on,
as well as for deriving
operational insights that we
can take advantage of in
the moment, as they occur.
So you've heard a
lot about Pub/Sub
as a streaming data
ingestion source.
Pub/Sub can also
be used as a source
to be written to that's the
output of a streaming data
pipeline.
Now, in this example,
I've enriched our pipeline
with some additional
capabilities that
can leverage
Pub/Sub's capability
to notify downstream consumers
of useful information.
The first of this is a
product lookup web service.
The product lookup web service
enriches the purchased goods
information from the
checkout, and then adds
additional information.
So it's an example of a way
to enrich incoming data,
and then add additional
information that
comes from external sources, and
then write that information out
to either a batch source
or to a streaming source.
The second piece of
information that we'll
be incorporating via external
sources into the pipeline
is an inventory web service.
And this could
potentially hold things
like stock level and other
inventory-related information.
Now, as purchases are being
made from the point-of-sale
checkout, we're going to be
integrating with the inventory
web service to update
some information,
such as the stock
level for product,
as well as to produce alerts
on particular products that are
seeing spikes in consumption--
which may be an indicator of a
stock out situation in store,
hypothetically.
So with that in mind, I'd like
to go into the demo to show you
what that might look like.
So this next screen
that I'm bringing up
is our new enhanced pipeline.
And you can simply
see, by counting
the number of rectangles
on the screen,
it must be doing something
pretty cool, right?
So I'm going to
not talk about all
the different transformations
that we're applying.
This is producing some
analytical insights as well as
some operational insights.
But I'm going to talk about the
real-time stock notification
that I've talked about earlier.
So how can we notify
Bill's Grocer's stores
whenever there's a threshold
of a particular product
that's been exceeded--
being purchased in a
short period of time?
So let's see how that
actually happens.
So first off, we still need
to read the information.
So instead of reading individual
purchase information now,
we're actually reading
whole invoices,
where there's one or
more purchases within it.
When we're doing
that, we can perform
more interesting analytics,
things like, obviously,
what is the average
size of an order,
and other information like that.
After we read the
information, we
can augment that information
with additional information
from our product lookup service,
which is where I'm actually
hovering over right now.
I want to focus on the
operational insights
that we can enable
by detecting spikes
in purchasing activity
for particular products.
And this is the part of the
pipeline which does that.
In order to understand
statistics and information that
occur within a
period of time, we
apply a technique
called windowing.
In this particular case, it's
a sliding window aggregation
across streaming data that
includes timestamp information
that allows us to then count
the number of occurrences
of a particular purchase
over that period of time,
and then, if it exceeds
a certain threshold,
write a particular message
to a Pub/Sub topic,
which is then used by downstream
consumers to display an alert.
So that's basically the
"write alerts to Pub"--
actually, it should
be "Pub/Sub"--
that's what that particular
transformation is doing.
So I think, at this
point, it might
be more useful to
actually show this
in action in our
hypothetical store scenario.
So, Reza?
REZA ROKNI: Sure.
So as I open that one,
I'll start using this one.
WIN WOO: Oh.
OK.
REZA ROKNI: OK?
WIN WOO: All right.
No.
So you need to go and
start a new order, like so.
REZA ROKNI: OK.
So let's assume that it's been
a particularly heavy usage
of this.
It's a little bit
towards the end of day,
and we're looking
for some sugar fix.
WIN WOO: I think you're just
selling me the one product,
and then charging for six.
REZA ROKNI: [LAUGHS]
WIN WOO: I think I'm getting
the short end of the stick here.
Yup.
Great.
REZA ROKNI: OK.
WIN WOO: OK.
All right.
So someone is obviously a big
fan of these chocolate biscuits
original, of which I'm
only getting one packet.
But what this is doing
is sending the invoice
as one Pub/Sub payload
into our pipeline,
and then via the
streaming aggregation
that's being applied
to the streaming data,
we should see an alert
come up to say that there's
a potential stock alert that
has now happened in the Penrith
store in New South Wales.
And so you see, up on the
screen-- or hopefully there--
that there's a stock alert
for that particular product.
So this is an example of
some operational insight
that you can get
from streaming data,
not just things that are
written out to a BigQuery table.
So there's different ways that
we can operationalize insight
that happens in real
time as well as for later
downstream analysis.
So with that, I'll
pass back to William.
And I'll also press
the button for you.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE: All right.
Thank you.
So now we can eat.
We're done with the props?
We can start eating them?
OK.
Good.
It's been three days.
We've been looking at this
packet and not touching it.
So having done the
DataFlow demo-- one thing I
forgot to mention.
DataFlow supports
Java, Python, Scala,
that our friends at
Spotify contributed.
There's a Go SDK
that's almost ready.
So there's a choice
of languages here.
And, yeah-- I see the
biscuits are passing.
See?
That's why you want
to sit in the front.
You get the biscuits, so
lesson learned for next time.
Let's talk about
another service--
DataProc.
So the services we've
talked about so far--
Pub/Sub, BigQuery, DataFlow--
those are cognitive services,
really built from scratch to run
in a serverless mode on Google
Cloud.
Obviously, there's also a
lot of very valuable systems
in the open source community.
And in the bigger data
space, Spark and Hadoop
are really two
that come to mind.
And we want to make sure
that customers on GCP
can use whatever the
right tool for the job is.
And so if the right
tool is Spark or Hadoop,
because of some
library, some tool,
or they've written already a lot
of pipelines on-prem and want
to run that on GCP, DataProc
makes that very easy by taking
Hadoop and Spark-- the
same Hadoop and Spark,
the same bits from
Apache everyone uses--
and deploying them, deploying
a cluster in about 90 seconds.
By the way, you
pay by the second.
And so those clusters--
you know, it's a normal
Hadoop and Spark cluster,
but it's also a very
dynamic cluster.
You can start and
you can stop it.
And what it changes is
the way people typically
use it on Cloud,
where they don't
have those long-lived clusters
that people have to share,
and you have to update
them, and agree on version.
It's a much more
dynamic way of getting
a cluster for whatever job
you want to run, and keep it
for one job, for one
day, for one week,
and really free yourself
from all the administration
while keeping access to the
power, and the ecosystem,
and all the tools available.
And so when you use it, you
can see on the left side
our Jobs API, where
you can run your jobs,
and you can write them using all
the common tools in the Spark
and Hadoop ecosystem,
and those jobs
execute on all the same
data storage systems
that we talked about.
And so I mentioned the clusters
come up in about 90 seconds.
When the cluster is up, you
can start working right away.
The next step is not
bring data to the cluster.
And again, remember, no silo.
Those Hadoop and Spark
clusters can execute on data
in BigQuery, on data in
Google Cloud Storage,
on data in Bigtable directly.
And that really lets you mix and
match, across your environment,
services like
BigQuery and DataFlow,
whether cloud native, with
Hadoop and Spark using
DataProc, and use
that all together.
You know, again, use the
right tool for the job.
And so that's a really
powerful part of DataProc.
And let's look at
it in practice.
WIN WOO: All right.
So soon, again.
OK.
So I think we're done with
our checkout, so I can close
this window, and, instead, show
you the DataProc console inside
of the Cloud Platform console.
So here we're seeing the
DataProc list of clusters.
And I've got one
pre-prepared here.
But because DataProc
starts up very quickly,
I'm going to create
a cluster on the fly.
So let's give it a slightly
unique name, like so.
I'm going to leave these
sensible defaults, for the most
part, but maybe change some
specific things I'll call out
when I'm creating
my DataProc cluster.
So the first thing
is maybe I want
to specify a particular
region where it runs.
So all my data is
in US Central One,
so it makes sense to do that.
We're using the
sensible defaults
that I have for a very simple
job that I'm going to spin up,
which is two worker nodes.
I'm going to click
into Advanced Options
here before creating my cluster.
And the first thing I want
to do in the advanced options
is to allow API
access from my cluster
so that my cluster can call
different Google Cloud Platform
services to do
interesting things,
as well as install some
additional dependencies, which
I'll ultimately need for my job.
So I click on Browse.
I'm going to point my
DataProc configuration
at a particular script
that I want DataProc
to run, to install
some dependencies,
and then click on Select.
And from here, I should
be able to click on Create
and have my cluster spun up
with my custom dependencies
available on each worker.
So to this point in
time, I've not actually
described what my
job actually does.
So let me rectify that
particular situation.
Actually, I can
click on Buckets here
to show you this information.
Inside of our project, we have
some hypothetical customer
feedback that some
customers have
sent to us, of which we're
going to try and analyze
using a batch processing job
with our Cloud Natural Language
API so we can understand the
sentiment of those emails
and, thereby, be informed
of some actions to take,
because there's a potentially
unsatisfied customer
that we want to keep in touch
with or get in touch with.
So let's have a look at
the emails, or the input.
So we're in the Spark directory
here, which contains my input.
I've got two emails
here as text files.
And as you can imagine,
these text files actually
contain some
angry-sounding words in it,
and there's some customer
dissatisfaction there.
Let me just click on that
just to prove the fact
that this particular person--
Bob-- is not very happy.
But you can kind
of get the sense
of what's within these emails
and the sort of sentiment
that our batch processing job
should actually come back with.
And, of course, I
have my code as well.
So we're not here to basically
step through Python, so I
won't actually show you that.
But know that this is the
piece of code that I will then
run by submitting a Spark job--
or a PySpark job, more
specifically-- to the cluster.
So that was the data
that I want to show.
In order to submit a
job, I can actually just
click on a previous job here
and clone its configuration.
I want to do that because I
have all my previous parameters
already provided.
So I don't need to type them in.
You can see that
my Python file is
in this particular parameter.
I've got my input pointing
to the input directory, which
contains my emails,
and I want the output
to be sentiment analysis output
on each line in each email,
written to a CSV file.
Of course, the most
important element
is actually choosing
the cluster.
And the other clusters
actually come up now,
so that's why I've
got two available.
I'm going to choose this
particular cluster, click
on Submit--
oh.
Whoops.
I actually have to change
the actual job name
because it needs to
be unique, like so.
I'll click on Submit, and
my job should be running.
Now, if I click
into the actual job,
the streaming logging
output from Spark
should actually be displayed.
You'll see-- actually, it's
probably too small to see here.
But one interesting
aspect of DataProc
is its ability to talk directly
to Google Cloud Storage, much
like a normal HTFS data source.
So there's no code changes
that you need in order
to run a job on DataProc
and have your data stored
on Cloud Storage.
And you get all the
scaling benefits
of Google Cloud Storage as
an object storage source.
So I think now the job
is actually complete,
because I only have two emails.
In order to prove the
point, I'm going to go back
to my directory here.
And now there's an
output directory inside
of my emails bucket, and here's
the output of my analysis
with the batch processing job.
I'm going to actually leave the
output of the Natural Language
API as a discussion
for Reza, who
will talk about extending
this with some additional
capabilities.
So thank you, Reza.
REZA ROKNI: So one of
the interesting things
that Win highlighted
was the use of an API
to start extracting
some structure
from unstructured content.
And actually, when you're
building out on a platform,
you're investing in
that platform, what
you want that platform
to do is provide you
with all of the tools that you
need to do all of your work.
So a platform is a group of
technology used as a base
to build other things on top of.
And some of the other
tools that are available--
and we show a small
piece of it there--
is our machine
learning capabilities.
So things like Speech
Detect, Cloud Translation,
Natural Language
Understanding, these
are all APIs that you
want to be able to access
with your processing tools to
be able to extract information
from that wealth of
unstructured content.
Now, let's expand the
use case that we just
saw around the providing
sentiment against an email.
Now, this is actually
based off a real use case
with a retail customer.
Let's imagine you're
getting emails.
And what you want to do is,
when someone is particularly
angry or upset, you
would like to put them
onto a priority queue.
Because retaining
customers is expensive.
Losing customers is even worse.
And what you don't
want to do is,
if there's something that you
could remediate the situation
with-- for example, a
simple set of vouchers,
or a simple phone
call or an email--
to actually keep
that customer, you
should put them on top
of the priority list.
And one of our customers has
an amazing return on investment
by doing just this activity.
But we need to add
a little bit more.
So we can extract sentiment
using Natural Language
Processing API.
But we also-- because we're
storing this information
in other system,
we want to not have
the burden of actually taking
unnecessary information
into the other system.
So by that I mean, if, for
example, we have the user's
name, their email, they've
accidentally put their credit
card, we'd like help
to actually remove
this information
from that content
before we store
it somewhere else.
You know, we want to avoid
unnecessary proliferation
of PII information.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to add another piece,
which is the Data Loss
Prevention API.
So this uses things
like machine learning,
pattern matching,
mathematical checksums,
et cetera, to actually help
find sensitive information.
And then what it does is it
allows you to remove or star
over that information as you
store it in another location.
So what we're going to do now is
go through and just demo this.
What we're going to do is show
a particular DataFlow pipeline.
So we saw DataProc before with
the Natural Language Processing
API.
Here we have a DataFlow pipeline
that's going to be taking--
whenever a file lands in
Google Cloud Storage--
let's assume that's an email--
it's going to take
that file and it's
going to run it through
the two processes.
It's going to run it through
the Data Loss Prevention API,
and then the Natural
Language Understanding
API-- the NLP API.
And at the end of
that, it's going
to store that
information in BigQuery.
So right now, this is
processing up to three files.
So I'm going to go to
Google Cloud Storage,
go to our email
folder, go to Inbound,
and I do have an item ready--
upload files--
this angry British.
Obviously, there's
no swearing in it.
We don't do swearing in Britain.
So we've got an
angry British person
who's going to update
some information.
That has been uploaded
to this cloud storage.
If I go to our thing,
we're still at three.
What this will do is, when
it detects that that file has
landed, it's going to process
it and land it over here,
in this BigQuery table.
So I'm just going to
run this query here.
You can see a fourth
element has been added.
If I go back, we can see that
that incremented it up to four.
So that's been processed.
Let's look at what it's done.
So I think it was
this one that landed.
So here, there's a very
angry person who's--
the birthday cake for their
daughter's birthday party
arrived late.
It has redacted information,
like their credit card, which
they had put into the piece.
And it also redacted their name.
It was actually Reza, there.
We also have a sentiment score.
So this is negative four
with a high magnitude.
In other words, they were
quite cross about having
their birthday cake
arrive a day late.
We're almost there
in terms of having
a full footwork for a pipeline.
We've got-- as emails are coming
in, we're able to do this work
and add them into BigQuery.
But what we haven't got
is that final piece of,
how do we notify our support
people to actually go and do
something about this?
And for that, we
need a bit of glue
to stick several
processes together.
So over to William, quickly.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE: Thank you.
And we will switch
back to slide.
And so I think "glue" is a
good term as we describe it,
because we've been talking
about individual services
and what they can do.
But data processing is really
an end-to-end experience,
and you need something that
ties together those processing
systems, and gives you
control and visibility
and a unified point
of management.
And that's where Cloud
Composer comes in.
Composer is one of the newest
services on the platform.
It went generally
available this week.
It is a managed version
of Apache Airflow.
So if your familiar
with Apache Airflow--
which is, right now, in
the open source community,
the acquisition service
with the most momentum,
really, really loved by users.
And so we chose to use it,
make it available as a managed
service on the platform,
contribute to Airflow, bringing
operators that allow it to
act on all the relevant Google
Cloud Services, and make that
available with no deployment
to all our users, to easily
orchestrate and manage data
processing on Google Cloud.
And so let's see what it
looks like in practice.
Reza?
REZA ROKNI: OK.
So what we're going
to do now is add
that final piece,
which is orchestrate
moving the information that
exists in BigQuery into a CSV
file ready for
our support folks.
So I'm going to use
Google Airflow here--
sorry.
Google Composer, which is
running an Airflow job.
The DAG that I have
in mind is going
to do a query against
that BigQuery table,
look at the last
two hours, and then
its going to put the results
of that in another table,
ready to be exported
out as a CSV file.
So-- oh.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE:
You show the demo.
REZA ROKNI: So sorry.
Now I'll show you the-- yeah.
I forgot to hit the button.
Apologies for that.
So here we have the Airflow DAG.
This is the Notify Job.
If you can see, it
comes in two steps--
Recent Query, Query,
and then Export.
So I'm going to go and--
even though this DAG
has been scheduled
to run every two hours, I'm
going to just kick it off
by triggering the process now.
And in a moment, we'll see these
numbers-- we see it already,
that the job's been queued.
In a moment, we'll see
both of those tasks being
processed successfully
and the move happening.
What that will do is,
it will land a file--
if I go back to here--
into our same emails
but Priority folder.
So this is available
from the last run.
Let's go back here and see
if this is already completed.
I'm going to refresh the page.
OK.
One task still running.
We'll give that a
few more moments.
And what that will do is it's
run the BigQuery SQL statement,
it's pushed some data to another
table, it's done the CSV export
and landed that into
Google Cloud Storage.
So if I just refresh this--
there we go-- that
task is now completed.
If I go back to our
bucket and refresh this--
and now we download this file.
I'll open it.
So this file now--
since the last time it was
run, we have one more email
that we need to go and deal
with for this customer.
So here, Composer has been used
to glue separate activities
together to actually
generate a full workflow.
OK.
And with that, over to William.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE:
Thank you, Reza.
And back to the demo slides.
There we go.
And so actually, having talked
about the orchestration,
now we're going to talk
about the last stage
of the lifecycle, which
is all the tools--
not all, some of
the tools that you
can use to directly
interact with the data.
And Win is going to
demonstrate those for us.
WIN WOO: Sure.
Thank you, William.
So, up to this point
in time, we saw
a lot of SQL querying, which is
absolutely fantastic if you're
comfortable with those tools.
But sometimes you want to
visualize your information
in graphical ways, or
to explore your data
in intuitive environments
that let you discover insight
in a much more visual way than
what a SQL query can give you.
So to that end, I'm going to
show two different tools which
are integrated within the
Google Cloud platform--
or integrated with Google
Cloud platform, rather.
And those tools are
Google Data Studio,
which is a dashboarding and
visualization tool, more
recently, a data exploration
tool integrated directly
into a BigQuery.
And the second tool
that I'm going to show
is Google Spreadsheets,
which I think many of you
are familiar with
today, but we recently
just launched with a new
integration into BigQuery.
So let's go into
demonstration mode again.
OK.
The first thing I want to show
you is Data Studio Explorer.
And that is our intuitive
explorative environment
that integrates into BigQuery.
I want to go into one of
our BigQuery tabs here.
And again, I'll kickstart our
analysis using a saved query.
In this case, I'm going to be
interested in the top products
purchased together
with bakery goods.
This information is
actually computed--
or the table is
by the output from
our streaming pipeline
that does a lot more of
the operational insights
and the analytics
from previously.
So this query here is going
to run across, I think,
about 70 million rows, or
maybe even more, actually.
We're still receiving data,
so there's quite a lot
of information still coming in.
But it's going to be giving
us quite a lot of results.
And it should usually
finish right about now.
OK.
So in our output, we see that
there's individual product
combinations and the amount
of revenue associated
with the other product that's
being bought with a bakery
item.
This is quite difficult
to actually comprehend
in this interface, so
what I'm going to do now
is take this into exploration
mode via Data Studio Explorer.
So I've done that by clicking
on the Explore button inside
of the BigQuery interface.
And now I've got an
environment where
I can intuitively slice and
dice and explore the dataset
in a much more visual way.
On the right-hand side, we have
different ways to visualize
information using
different types of graphs--
scatter plots, line charts,
bar charts, that sort of stuff.
In this case, I'm going
to choose a pivot table
to show some specific insight
about how products are being
bought with bakery items, in
this case, how much revenue is
brought in in total
for all products bought
with bakery items.
So I'm going to change
one of the dimensions
here so that we're actually
looking at the product revenue.
So with that, we changed
the actual metric
into revenue instead
of frequency.
And we see that Bill's brand
organic honey is actually
doing really quite well.
So let's do another type of
visualization inside of Data
Studio Explorer.
And this time, let's
view the proportion
of revenue attached
to bakery goods
in the form of a pie chart.
So in this case, let's,
again, look at the metric
as product revenue.
So we'll drop that
in there like that.
Oh.
Actually, I think
it's already in there.
OK.
So let's just say that I'm
happy with this particular
visualization, and I
want to incorporate it
into a larger dashboard.
So what I can do now is
actually save this exploration.
And then, after this is saved,
I can export it to a report.
Oh.
Actually, I don't want
to create a new report,
because I've actually got a
great one ready to show you.
So I'm going to Copy
To Existing Report.
So this is going to
copy this pie chart,
and it's going to be
now available for me
to paste into an existing
dashboard that I already have.
So this is the dashboard here.
So this dashboard shows
the different types
of visualization capabilities
in one convenient screen.
So here you find
ways to visualize
information in tabular format
as well as line charts, bar
charts, and other types of
information-- or types of ways
to visualize
information, rather.
So let's just say I want
to incorporate my pie
chart into this dashboard.
What I'm going to do is paste my
pie chart into this dashboard,
and then fill out the last
missing piece of information
I want to show, and
then bring it down.
Now, if you use
G-Suite products,
you might know
that a lot of it is
real-time collaboration based.
And Data Studio, in this
respect, is no different.
So I think, right
now, I've actually
got William, or somebody
posing as William--
i.e.
Reza-- inside the
dashboard at the same time,
working to update the dashboard
for improved aesthetics,
as you can see right now.
So this is a great real-time
collaboration tool,
where you can work with
others to create a dashboard,
and then share it
to other people
for further
collaboration, or to just
visualize the dashboard as a
consumer of this information.
OK.
And Reza has very
helpfully just shrunk
my graph for me,
which has, again, made
an aesthetic improvement.
I think it's now ready to
then share with somebody else.
So let's complete
the final step,
and share it to Kelly,
which is somebody that
is interested in this insight.
I can send the report
to that person.
They'll get a link, and
then they can basically
see the same dashboard
as well-- oh, actually,
maybe not in this
particular case.
Let's try one more time.
Let's say view, instead.
And yes.
And there you go.
Kelly now has access.
So there you go.
I want to pass over
to Reza to show
one final piece, which is
the Google Spreadsheets
integration.
REZA ROKNI: So this was very
recently announced as well.
So this is Google Sheets.
And just very quickly,
going to run through here.
In the sheet, if I go
to the Data column--
so I'm in Google Sheets now--
at the bottom, we now
have data connectors.
And we can choose BigQuery.
Here, I'll be able
to choose a project.
So let's go to our
DA Next project.
Do it right.
Here we see the
information, the datasets,
et cetera available to us.
If I just go back here, I have
created a dataset already.
If you remember, we were
scanning some products in.
This happens to be the product
code that was available.
Here, we have the
sheet which is actually
going to that table and
existing information.
If I refresh the
sheet, it's going
to get the very latest data
that we had, based off the demo.
So these were the
last items, and plenty
of chocolate biscuits were
being bought in this time.
So this is very quick, nice and
easy Google Sheets integration
with BigQuery.
OK.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE:
Thank you, Reza.
Let's switch back to the slides.
And so, having shown an overview
of the platform and services
like Pub/Sub, BigQuery,
DataFlow, DataProc,
we here use this
simplified example,
with this pseudo point-of-sale
and simplified example,
really just to show what
each product does in a very
concrete and applied way.
But now, let's look at
a real life scenario
and how that's being used
by, in this case, Moloco.
And Hooyeon Lee is joining us
to talk about their experience
on the platform.
[APPLAUSE]
HOOYEON LEE: Thank you,
William, for the introduction.
My name is Hooyeon Lee.
I'm a research
scientist at Moloco.
I've been with Moloco
for about two years.
The green button?
Yeah.
So I'll briefly talk
about the company, Moloco,
and what we do.
So we are a mobile
ad tech company
that turns big data into ad
performance using machine
learning models.
Our clients use us for marketing
purposes, like user acquisition
and reengagement, as well as
monetization of their products.
Our cloud solution
is deeply integrated
with Google Cloud Platform.
So in particular, we use the
Bigtable, BigQuery, DataFlow,
and Pub/Sub--
the products that you
saw in this session.
Some of the challenges we faced
while building a scalable ad
cloud solution can be summarized
as these three things.
And I'm going to talk
about how we have overcome
these challenges using some of
the products of Google Cloud
Platform.
So the first thing
that comes to my mind
is the small latency
requirement with high volume
of network traffic.
So for mobile advertisement,
as soon as a user opens an app
and that shows an ad
like an image or video,
we receive an event that
is called a bit request
from the bit exchange servers.
So those are
third-party services
that we are integrated with.
And as soon as we
receive a bit request,
we have to respond
within 100 milliseconds.
We have to determine
whether we want
to participate in
this real-time auction
or not, and how much price
we're willing to pay,
and what kind of image or
videos we want to serve,
and if the user
clicks on it, where
the user should be directed to.
So we have to do all that
under 100 milliseconds
for each request, and we receive
about over 600,000 bit requests
per second, at peak, and we
receive over 40 billion bit
requests per day.
So that is one of the challenges
we faced, and latency is
a big problem we have to solve.
So for that, we use Bigtable.
I'll talk a little bit
more about this later.
Transforming big data into
machine learning models
is another challenge.
We use a lot of complex
machine learning models.
And to do that, we have
to be able to process
a large volume of
data, and we have
to transform that
data into something
that our machine
learning algorithms
can process and digest.
So we use DataFlow for that.
And we process over 100
terabytes of new data
on a daily basis.
And we also have
the accumulated data
over the course of
two to three years
that we use to train our
machine learning models.
The third challenge was to
find a collaborative tool that
can handle big data as
well as complex analysis.
So for that, we use BigQuery.
As you saw from the
demos by Win and Reza,
we use BigQuery to
save views or queries
and share those with
the team members.
Our data scientists
and modelers want
to analyze big data using
complex queries, SQL,
or user-defined functions,
and also sometimes
its very helpful to share
the queries themselves.
So with that in mind,
I'm going to give you
a high-level overview of how we
are using each of these Google
Cloud platform products
to build our application.
So on the left-hand
side, you see two boxes
that are labeled as
real-time bidding
exchanges and mobile
measurement platforms.
So those are the
third-party services
that we are integrated with.
There are dozens of them, and we
receive live traffic from them.
So as soon as we receive a bit
request or some other events
from these services,
Google's load balancer
will handle them and re-route
them to our live bid servers.
Our live bid servers
are written in Golang,
and they are running on
top of Kubernetes engine.
So those two red boxes
represent our serving module.
There are some other
components, like Pub/Sub,
but it's not in this
diagram, because we
are going to focus on data
processing in this session.
So for big data processing, we
primarily use four products--
DataFlow along with BigTable,
BigQuery, and Google Cloud
Storage.
So I'm going to talk
more about these products
and how we use them.
For modeling, especially
handling large datasets,
TensorFlow is an open source
library released by Google,
and most of our
machine learning models
are written using TensorFlow.
So if we zoom into data
processing, as I mentioned,
we process over 100 terabytes
of data on a daily basis.
So DataFlow jobs can
read from and write
to BigTable,
BigQuery, Google Cloud
Storage, including Pub/Sub, as
you saw from the demo earlier.
So we use DataFlow to primarily
transform one complex data
structure into another.
So we keep transforming
data depending on our needs,
and then eventually
our goal is to make
it available at the time of
bidding so that we can make
an informed decision about
how we want to participate
in a real-time auction, and also
to train our machine learning
models.
So on a daily basis, we run
over 250 DataFlow batch jobs,
and some of the largest jobs
use over 4,000 virtual CPUs
per job.
And most of our jobs are CPU
intensive because they're
transforming a very complex
data structure to another.
We also utilize DataFlow's
service-based shuffle.
It's an opt-in feature
that you can use.
I'm going to talk about
this a little later.
And it actually gave us
huge performance gains
in terms of throughput per cost.
Before I talk about
some of the benefits
we got by using
Google Cloud Platform,
I also want to
emphasize how we were
able to scale while keeping
the costs low in the past two
years.
So we have grown from
serving 60,000 QPS to 600,000
QPS in the past two years.
So this is 10 times of
growth in the number of bids.
So here in the chart,
the x-axis is the month,
and the y-axis on
the left-hand side
is the number of
bids or auctions
we participated in
in a given month.
And the blue bars
represent that.
So you can clearly see a
fast growing trend here.
The red line represents
the unit cost--
our unit infra cost per bid.
So it's been going down
by a factor of three
the past two years.
So we have been able to do
that, even though our developer
team was pretty small.
We started with two
full-time engineers,
and now we're about 10
full-time engineers.
The whole company has
grown from about, I think,
seven people to about 45 people
now in the past two years.
So we were able to do that
because our IT operations
burden was very low.
So most of the products that
we use on Google Cloud Platform
are handled by Google Cloud
engineers and Google Cloud
support teams.
So we don't have to worry
about operating those tools--
like, for example, Bigtable,
BigQuery, and DataFlow.
We just have to worry about
improving our applications
and cloud solutions.
So we were able to improve
our tools, build new features,
and add more tools,
but we didn't really
have to focus human resources
on this operations aspect.
So that way we were able to
grow really fast, scale up
really fast, while keeping
the unit costs very low,
and here, the unit cost
in terms of infra bill
as well as human resources.
So in summary, I can list these
four benefits of using GCP.
And then, in the
next two slides,
I'm going to talk a little
more about specific use case
studies--
how we benefited from using GCP.
So the first thing that comes
to my mind is a pay-as-you-go
pricing model.
So when we were a
very small company,
we were not able to commit to
a huge amount of resources,
like CPUs, or memory,
or virtual machines,
because we were not
receiving that much traffic.
But now, if you are building
a scalable application,
keeping the unit costs
the same or lower
will be very
beneficial as you grow,
because overall, your
application's scalability
is going up as long as
your unit price is at level
or going down.
So that's exactly what we did.
And now that we have
grown quite a bit,
we are also utilizing what
is called the Committed Use
Discount.
So we have committed to use
a certain amount of vCPUs
and virtual machines in
each of the major regions
that Google Cloud
Platform provides,
so we are able to cut down
our infra bill as well.
Another aspect is--
this was mentioned
earlier in the session,
too-- but easy integration
among many products of GCP.
In particular, in my
personal experience,
using DataFlow together with
Bigtable, BigQuery, and Google
Cloud Storage has
been very useful,
because they provide a lot of
useful APIs and documentation.
So operationally,
we didn't really
need a separate
operations team that is
separate from developers team.
So we didn't really
need to worry
about how we're going to manage
or operate or deploy some
of the services
offered by Google Cloud
Platform, because they
are all handled by Google.
So that has been
very useful for us.
Stack Overflow is
a great resource
for asking technical questions
on some of these products.
Personally, I've asked a bunch
of questions about DataFlow
and Bigtable on Stack Overflow,
and the team members--
team engineers at Google--
actually responded to
some of my questions.
And they were very helpful.
So that's one of the great
resources-- public resources--
you can utilize.
In the next two
slides, I'm going
to talk more specifically
about our case studies of how
we utilize DataFlow's
service-based shuffle, which
is an opt-in feature,
and also, how
we use the BigTable and
BigQuery as complements
to overcome the three major
challenges I mentioned earlier.
So Dataflow
service-based shuffle
is basically an opt-in
feature that DataFlow back end
server provides.
So you pay based on
the amount of data
processed by the server.
But in exchange,
your job's throughput
and performances in
terms of just duration
are expected to get better.
So in this chart, the top
chart shows the same job CPU
utilization without
the shuffle service,
and the bottom chart shows
it with the shuffle service.
So the images are
of the same size,
but the first job
took about four hours,
and the second job
took about three hours.
And y-axis is the
CPU utilization.
As I mentioned earlier,
most of our jobs
are very CPU intensive.
So if CPU utilization
is low, that
means our job's
throughput is not at peak.
So clearly, you can see how it
is better with the second job
when we turned on
the shuffle service.
And overall, you can also save--
because your job
duration is shorter,
you will pay less
for the resources
you used for running
those DataFlow jobs.
But you can also save
your costs by cutting down
memory or disk space used
by these DataFlow jobs.
So overall, in this specific
case, it gave us a three times
improvement in
throughput per cost,
and we used this shuffle service
for some of our batch jobs
whenever it is applicable.
Another thing I
want to emphasize
is how we use Bigtable,
BigQuery DataFlow together as
complements.
So, as I mentioned earlier,
one of the challenges
we have is latency requirement.
So Bigtable for quick
access is basically
how we have overcome
the first challenge.
Bigtable offers quick
key-value operations,
both read and write, at 10,000
QPS under six millisecond.
And that's actually very
quick, and we really
need this to meet the 100
millisecond requirement.
And it also offers fast
scans using DataFlow--
so 200 megabytes per second--
and this is per node.
So we store a lot
of data in BigTable
that is required for determining
whether we want to participate
in a real-time bidding or not.
And also, for our
machine learning models,
they have to determine
what bid price
we are going to write and
submit to those exchanges.
So we have a lot of
data stored in Bigtable,
and DataFlow is one way to
scan through this Bigtable
and store the resulting dataset
in BigQuery or Google Cloud
Storage.
Also, garbage collection is
very easy with different types
of garbage collection policies.
So that's another useful
feature for Bigtable.
And BigQuery is more suitable
for complex analysis.
So our data scientists
and modelers
would use BigQuery to analyze
complex data, including
our training datasets for
machine learning models.
So SQL and user-defined
functions are supported.
And also, we use stream inserts
for real-time monitoring
and analytics.
So our live bid
servers will stream
insert some of the data--
like logs, and some metrics--
to BigQuery tables.
And also, as you
saw from the demo,
it is very easy to
share queries and views.
So this basically solved
our third challenge,
where we needed a collaborative
tool that can handle big data,
and it's very easy to share
within the organization.
And also, as you
saw from the demo,
garbage collection policy or
table expiration can be set,
so that's another plus.
To utilize both
of these products,
we use DataFlow as
the main product
that does data transformation.
So specifically for our
machine learning pipeline,
we have to generate a large
collection of datasets
to train our models
and evaluate them.
So most valuable
information or dataset
is stored in Bigtable, because
they are read and written
by our live bid servers.
So we use DataFlow job to
scan the whole Bigtable
and dump that data to
Google Cloud Storage as well
as BigQuery.
The reason we write the
data to two different places
is because Google Cloud Storage
is basically just a storage.
We store all of our data there.
On the other hand, BigQuery is
suitable for complex analysis.
So we are going to
transform this data--
the same data that we
read from Bigtable--
in a way that our
modelers and data
scientists can easily analyze
on BigQuery using SQL.
So that's how we generate
machine learning training
datasets, and then
our TensorFlow models
will train from those datasets.
So just to wrap up,
Moloco has grown rapidly
in the past two
years, and scalability
has been the key to our growth.
Google Cloud Platform helped
us to focus more on developing
our application--
ad cloud solution--
without having to worry about
operating some of these cloud
services that you saw
from this session.
So in particular, by using
Bigtable, BigQuery, DataFlow,
we were able to overcome
those three major challenges I
mentioned in the first
slide, and that's
how we have been able to
work with some of the largest
clients we have, like
largest e-commerce
in Asia, or one of the largest
electronic device makers.
So with that, I'm going to
give this back to William.
And, yeah, thank you.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE: Thank
you very much, Hooyeon.
Thank you.
And so, just in closing, you
see those three principles
which I described in an
abstract way at the beginning.
Hopefully, by now, you
see how, in practice,
the data integration delivers
on the integrated part,
or Composer tying
things together,
how Pub/Sub and DataFlow and
BigQuery really exemplify
serverless for data
processing, and how,
whether it's bringing the best
of open-source to Google with
DataProc, with Composer,
or vice versa--
bringing Google technology to
open-source with TensorFlow,
and Apache Beam, and others--
we live by this
principle of everything
we do being based
on open technology.
And so, hopefully, that
gave you a quick overview
of how we apply those
principles, a quick overview
of the capabilities of
some of the key services.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC ENDS]